john means who's been terrific ben in
his first two years you see what he's
done
only the one hit against boston probably
his best start of his career 190
opponents batting average nothing to
complain about
ty france coming up with one out he's
been on base a lot mike in fact he's
been on base 18
times over the first nine games
two two a center cut and
pummeled out to left on its way back and
gone home run tied france
number two of the season and two batters
in the mariners
are in front
well aaron it's always nice to score
first but especially when you're playing
seven innings
100 on the exit velocity 380 feet for
france ends up getting a change up we've
talked about him the way i like to stay
in the middle of the field this is a
change but if you make a mistake with an
off speed pitch
he typically will get the barrel on at
84 miles an hour
hits it out of the ballpark
sheffield he's five foot ten 195 pounds
24 years old from tullahoma tennessee
that's where david hess is from
most recent outing for him came last
monday
against the chicago white zone great
lineup
mancini firmly on the ground seeger
france onto first plenty of time
around the horn they go for the double
play catcher tom murphy leading off the
top half of the second
camden yards here in baltimore a very
cozy ballpark especially to left field
here's the wind-up band the pitch swung
on and a well-hit ball to left field
going back is stewart looking up and
goodbye baseball
halfway into the bleachers tom murphy
with his first home run of the season
second of the ball game already for the
mariners france it won in the first
murphy here in the second and the
mariners jump out to a two-nothing lead
over the orioles
great to see murph start to get on track
needed that broken oh for six and he got
all of it man he hit that ball hard look
at the reaction
inside the barriers dugout for tom
murphy
taylor tremell now and tremella's first
pitch honey
out the other way to left d.j stewart in
the corner
has got it went into a safety slide up
near the wall and a fabulous play made
by stuart and left boy this was a much
tougher play than what he made it look
ball slicing off the left-handed bat
from tramell slicing away towards the
left field line and what an outstanding
effort a good catch
two on one out the three-two
part hit up the middle and into center
field evan white
coming around gingerly on that hamstring
evan white crosses home mitch haniger
has reached base
every game this season and he makes it a
three-nothing mariners lead in the
second
i think this is a change-up away from
him finds a hole back up the middle and
you can see evan white
he is being careful with it as he should
be
fastball center cut seeger smothers
picks himself
up the stretch by evan white two down
terrific play smokes what a play by
kyle seeger and third base sharply hit
on the ground into the hole it's short
quickly to his left diving for that ball
gets up
spins around picks up the target and
fires a strike to evan white to get the
outer severino two down what a play
hot corner stepping a dive fine all-star
tight play good stretch by whitey at the
back end so
two outs seeger with a great play there
he started the double play in the first
one two oh there you go
88 this time as he puts a little extra
extra on the slider so we saw 87 with
the strikeout and then 88 on this one
but watch where it starts
you see where severino is around the
outside corner the ball starts in the
zone which is always the key with two
strikes you want it to be a strike to
the hitter
out of the hand this one is done
perfectly it's in the zone in the zone
and then as
it lasts three or four feet it's out of
the zone can't do it much better than
that
the one-two pitch that is a strike three
called on the outside corner with a
change up
and down goes evan white for the third
out of the inning and back to back one
two three innings
for john means it's still three nothing
seattle as we go to the bottom of the
fourth on the
miss last year stage three colon cancer
and has
made his way back to the majors an
everyday guy for the orioles
on the ground seeger france onto first
and evan white able to stay on the bag
to get out number two now an infield
base hit for santander
here in the fourth that's been it off at
justice he has three strikeouts along
the way and he's kept the ball on the
ground
in the early part of the ball game
here's the pitch on the way swinging a
ground ball snared at first making a low
lighter caught by evan white
with a reach to his right diving for the
ball evan white
robbing franco of the base in and that
will retire the
side but he kind of weathered the storm
he kept working
on 3-2 nubs a change up maria's has to
go a long way got it out of his glove
got it into mancini's nice play ramon
urias
nine in a row retired by means another
good pitch by means an off-speed pitch
in the ball
captain urias was kind of shaded over
behind second base so a long way for him
to go
he comes running in gets it in the glove
out of the glove quickly because
henniger can get down the line
he has sneaky power he has sneaky
opposite field power and that could
do him some good against justice
sheffield 2-1 to ramon urias
here's the pitch and it's hit deep to
right center field
drifting back as heineker still going
back still going back
and that baby's gone a two-run homer
for ramon urias it's a 3-2 ball game
here at camden yards
we mentioned the pop we mentioned the
opposite field pop
and on cue urias delivers uris
sent it over the right field fence great
job staying true to the opposite field
approach scott would be going to his
closer to face the
big teeth in the order mancini a lift
into right field henniger covering some
ground
and he's able to make the catch sliding
up against the wall
that's a big out number two
and a similar catch we saw on the home
stand
slider is hammered into left field this
could be two
mount castle turns bishop comes up throw
it a second
and the orioles have the tying run to
second on a laser of a double
from ryan mout castle you talk about own
time
and own playing for this slide he rifles
it right
down the left field line bishop quickly
gets to but mount castle has got to
get into scoring position with two
outright and he does easily
a chance for dj stewart and the orioles
to tie this up mariners go into the
overshift
with france and shallow right
a one there's his swing and a ground
ball through the left side base hit
mount castle waved around third bishop
comes up throwing to the plate
save mount castle beats it up to second
dj
stewart he's got an rbi single and the
orioles have tied the game up at three
in the bottom of the seventh
montero had the first two but mount
castle doubles
and then stewart drives him in with an
opposite field single
well we're going into extra innings we
go to the top half of the eighth the
mariners have the orioles all tied at
three to three for
comes a 1-1 head hard
center field and deep giving or chases
mullins running out of room it goes off
the face of the
fence hannigan rounding third he's going
to score
easily and kyle seeger clutches
big time for the mariners here they have
a 4-3 lead
here in the 8th inning on a 1-1 pitch he
hit it off the center field
wall that was a blast 0-2
ground ball right there to jp crawford
the mariners take
game one of the doubleheader in
baltimore